you uh dodged this question in an
interview i listened to
uh so let me ask you again here
uh what makes for a beautiful program
what makes for a beautiful program yeah
what are the characteristics you see
like you just said literate programming
what are the characteristics you see in
a program that make you sit back and say
that's pretty good
well the reason i didn't answer is
because there are
there are dozens and dozens of answers
to that because because
each you can define beauty
the same personal you find beauty a
different way from hour to hour i mean
it depends on what
and what you're looking for
at one level you it's it's beautiful
just if it works at all
another level it's beautiful if it's
if it uh
uh
it can be understood easily
it's beautiful if it
uh
if it's illiterate programming it's
beautiful it makes you laugh i mean yeah
i'm actually so i'm with you i think
beauty
if it's readable
readable yeah if you understand what's
going on and also understand
the elegance of thought behind it
and then
also as you said wit and humor
i was always uh i remember having this
conversation i had this conversation on
stack overflow
whether humor is good in comments
and i think it is whether humor is good
in comments like when you add comments
in code yeah
i always thought a little bit of humor
is good
it shows personality
it shows character shows wit and fun and
all those kinds of things
of the personality of the programmers
yeah okay so uh
a couple days ago i received a
a wonderful present from my former
editor at aston wesley he
he's downsizing his house and he found
uh
that
somebody at the company had
had found all that all of their internal
files about the art of computer
programming from the 1960s and they gave
it to him
uh and then uh you know before throwing
the threat in the garbage
and then so he said oh yeah he keep
planning to keep it for posterity but
now he realized that posterity is a
bit too much for him to handle so he
sent it to me
and so
and so i just received
this big big stack of
of letters uh
some of which i had written to them but
but many of which they had written to
early guinea pigs who were
telling them whether they they should
publish or not you know
and one of the things
was uh
uh
in in the uh in the comments to volume
one uh
uh
the the major the major reader was was
bob floyd
uh
who is my great
uh coworker in the 60s um died early
unfortunately but but uh
and and he
he commented about the humor
so we had you know he drank by me you
know says
you know keep this joke in or not you
know um
they also sent it out to focus group
what do you think about humor
in a book about computer programming
what's the conclusion and i stated my
philosophy is it said you know the ideal
thing
is uh
that it's it's it's something where
the reader knows that there's probably a
joke here if you only understood it and
this is a motivation
to understand
to think about it a little bit
um but anyway it it it's a very delicate
humor is a bit i mean it's
it's really uh
each each century invents a different
kind of humor too i mean
and
different cultures have different
different kinds of humor um yeah like uh
we might we talked about russia a little
bit offline uh you know there's dark
humor
and
you know what
when a country goes to something
different right any of that life and
stuff like this and
hey yo and jack benny i mean
steve allen wrote this book about
humor and it was the most boring book
but he was one of my i idols but
but uh
yeah
it's called the funny men or something
like that but yeah okay so anyway i i
think it's important to know that
that this is part of life and
and it should be fun and not yeah and
and so you know i wrote this
this organ composition which
uh is based on the bible but i didn't
refrain from putting little jokes in it
also in the music
it's hidden in the music it's it's it's
there yeah
a little humor is okay yeah i mean
not egregious humor
so in in this correspondence you know
there were
things i said yeah i really shouldn't
have
i really shouldn't have done that
but
but other ones i
know i insisted on and i've got
jokes in there
that no that nobody has figured out you
in fact
in volume 2
i've got a
cryptogram a message in cypher
and in order to decipher it you're going
to have to
have to break an rsa key which is
larger than people know how to break
and so
you know if computers keep getting
faster and faster then you know might be
100 years but somebody will figure out
what this message is and they will laugh
i mean i've got a joke in there
so that one you really have to work for
you